6788 c'est le nombre d'app domino
réalisé par roger prévost 81 ans
le défi a lieu sous les yeux de ses amis
ou de curieux à l'hôtel de ville de
tours roger ancien champion de france de
musculation à souhaitait battre son
record celui de 2001 il avait fait une
série de 1052 abdos en une heure il faut
soutenir ce monsieur parce que quand on
sera dans quel état 82 ans
enfin 80 at il dit parce que c'est quand
même remarquable à cet âge
ça prouve bien que le sport conserve les
81 ans ça justifie par l'alimentation je
suppose en premier il a été discret mais
je sais qu'il sait il s'entraînait tous
les jours avec des périodes assez
longues d'ailleurs surtout sur l'hygiène
de vie sur ses repas il a été très très
vigilants pas de fromage pas de
pâtisserie pas de cigarettes et
seulement un petit verre de vin parfois
le week end une hygiène de vie quasi
exemplaire avec les 6788 abdou rejet
prévost détient le record du monde du
nombre d'app domine en une heure il n'a
pas atteint les 7000 qui l'avaient visé
mais le bonheur était grand aujourd'hui
l'octogénaire s'entraînait à limeray
dans sa salle de sport depuis un an une
heure par jour
c'est pas toujours facile c'est pas
toujours évident j'avais un petit peu
trop de bruit avec certaines personnes
que j'entendais parler là alors ça me
gênait un petit peu quoi bein enfin bon
c'est pas déçu ça
faut quand même pas un âge que j'ai
lancé encore c'était 6052 ça fait 16 ans
j'ai 16 ans de plus et je le pulvérise
coin voilà tourner dans dix ans on verra
ça le défi à peine terminée l'huissier
de justice doit maintenant dresser un
procès-verbal attestant des conditions
de ce record est du nombre d'app de
réaliser rejet prévost figure à l'année
prochaine dans le guinness book des
records